I know it's hard to pick favorites but
what is your favorite matrix what's my
favorite matrix okay so my favorite
matrix is square I admit it's a square
bunch of numbers and it has twos running
down the main diagonal to end on the
next diagonal so think of top left to
bottom right twos down down the middle
of the matrix and minus ones just above
those twos and minus ones just below
those twos and otherwise all zeros so
mostly zeros just three nonzero
diagonals coming down what is
interesting about it well all the
different ways it comes up you see it in
engineering you see it as analogous in
calculus to second derivative so
calculus learns about taking the
derivative the figuring out how much how
fast something's changing but second
derivative now that's also important
that's how fast the change is changing
how fast the graph is bending how fast
it's it's curving and my Feinstein
showed that that's fundamental to
understand space so second derivatives
should have a bigger place in calculus
second mice matrices which are like the
linear algebra version of second
derivatives are neat in in linear
algebra yeah
just everything comes out right with
those guys beautiful
you